es el primer referendo a una ley
específica que se realiza en Cuba desde
la revolución de 1959 la votación Busca
determinar si se actualiza el código de
las familias que Data de 1975 entre
otros asuntos planea permitir el
matrimonio entre personas del mismo sexo
acabar con el matrimonio infantil el
cual el anterior código lo habilitaba de
forma excepcional con el visto bueno de
los padres implementar disposiciones
contra la violencia de género y
legalizar la gestación solidaria o como
se le conoce popularmente el alquiler de
vientres
cerca de 8 millones de cubanos
habilitados para votar responden sí o no
a la pregunta está usted de acuerdo con
el código de las familias
para bienestar social y de la población
yo quiera no
porque no estoy de acuerdo con eso
no estoy de acuerdo con un
sí estoy yo no estoy de acuerdo con esas
cosas que están pidiendo sobre el código
de la familia
el gobierno cubano ha realizado una
intensa campaña a favor del sí mientras
que aunque algunos sectores han
promovido el no no hay una campaña
articulada en contra del texto
anterior yo convoco a que analicemos el
código los reflexionamos desde el
corazón lo miremos con el corazón y
también que votemos por él con el
corazón será votar
es el único proyecto refrendado entre
las 70 normas jurídicas actualizadas con
la nueva constitución y aunque se espera
que este lunes la comisión electoral
Nacional de un avance del conteo
preliminar el resultado que requiere de
una mayoría simple será vinculante y se
conocerá dentro de cinco días